a man arrested after being found camping  out in singer Lana Del Rey's home he was  discovered in the garage of her Malibu  residents it's currently under  construction according to a local  detective del Rey was never confronted  by the fan and faced no threat of  violence the suspect left before police  arrived but police say that based on  several notes and a laptop he left  behind the man believed he had a quote  spiritual connection to the singer the  detective tells et based on ramblings he  was clearly infatuated the man was found  in Santa Monica on Tuesday and arrested  charges are pending et has reached out  to Lana for comment  interestingly enough the singer moved to  the Malibu property to escape over eager  fans TMZ reported in June